Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Hast du denn deine fünf Ringe dabei.
Selbstverständlich.
Willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik, äh eurem topaktuellen Olympia-Informationsdienst mit ohne Fail. Oder wir machen keinen Fehler.
Keine Fehler, das ist alles Absicht.
Genau, wir haben alle fünf Ringe äh am Start,
Ähm schönsten fand ich ja dieses dieses Bild, wo dann äh der fünfte Ring durch so ein broken Image-Link aus dem Let's Captain Navigator äh repräsentiert wurde.
Es gibt ja noch mehr so äh äh so Sachen irgendwie, was was diese äh kleinen äh Botschaften aus äh in diesem Sotschi-Ding angeht. Was ich auch sehr schön fand, die haben wohl als die ähm,
Als die russische Mannschaft da rein marschiert ist in dieses Eisstadion oder was das ist, da haben sie einen Song von Tattoo gespielt, das ist so eine äh waren so zwei Mädels, die irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren auch in den Charts waren,
und deren Musikvideo war in den USA zensiert, weil die beiden Mädels sich da geküsst haben.
Ja. Das fand ich jetzt auch interessant.
Mit dieser ganzen Homophobie Nummer drum herum ist das doch eine äh eine ganz coole äh.
Es ist wundert mich jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt fast ein bisschen. Na ja, vielleicht ist das ja so ein bisschen wie mit den Hotels.
Ich, ich hab's ich habe das nicht ich habe das äh ich saß in einem Lokal, in dem äh ein Fernseher lief, wo man das sehen konnte, aber ich hab's nicht gehört und ich habe mich da jetzt also Olympia setzt, setze ich mich jetzt auch nicht so vertieft mit auseinander.
Nee, ich auch nicht. Ich äh kriege das halt auch nur im Netz äh mit und mit dem Ganzen. Ja, also wer den Fail hat, äh braucht für Huhn und Sport ja nicht äh zu sorgen und ähm
Filmmäßig ist da einiges unterwegs. So, der Westen hält sich so ein bisschen den Bauch und muss ich, glaube ich, so ein bisschen daran abreagieren, dass er äh ansonsten Putin irgendwie immer mit allem durchkommt.
Ja. Ich weiß nicht, Olympia äh bitte bringt doch eh immer nur Leid und Elend dahin, wo man's macht, oder? Also, dieses, das kurbelt jetzt hier die, die Wirtschaft, also Olympia ist doch totaler, äh,
Ich weiß nicht, was das soll. Dann natürlich sind sie am Ende da und müssen die irgendwie den Rasen grün lackieren, weil weil Februar ist,
Da, also ich, ja klar, da kann man drüber lachen, aber irgendwie als in als in Südafrika irgendwie da eine WM aus dem Boden gestampft wurde, hat auch keiner gelacht, weil die Leute da irgendwie kaputt geknechtet wurden, um um die Stadien zu bauen. Also ich weiß nicht, ich bin da,
Ich kann auch nicht mitlachen, was also dass sie da in irgendwelchen Schrottbuden unterkommen in ja gut und jetzt so, dann,
Bucht euer Hotel halt früher. Wobei das Highlight war noch nicht fertig, ne?
Das äh war jetzt, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt so eine Gewinnerstrategie, also
konnte da, glaube ich, nur verlieren. Naja gut, also wir wollen's jetzt hier auch nicht mit Olympia äh beschäftigen, denn wir haben ja äh genug andere spannende, unterhaltsame Themen aus äh dem Netzpolitischen Bereich.
Auch Russland, ne? Also ich.
Ja, genau. Wo, du bist ja jetzt Russland-Experte.
Für Russlands Schönes, ja? Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, ja, ich lupfte eine Braue und stellte fest, nicht nur, weil Julian Assange äh ist bei Russia Today zu sehen, sondern auch der Linus.
Und vor mir auch der Julius einen Tag vorher, also es war russer, die sind da ganz äh ganz aktiv. Ähm,
Genau, da habe ich eine kleine, eine kleines Interview gegeben zu der Strafanzeige des CCC der internationalen Liga für die Menschenrechte und des Vereins Digitalcourage,
gegen oh, jetzt müssen wir mal hinkriegen. Die Bundesregierung, insbesondere die Bundeskanzlerin und den Bundesinnenminister,
Deutschen Geheimdienste und ihre Präsidenten sowie die britischen und US-Geheimnisse und ihre Präsidenten.
Geheimdienste. Nüsse, aber das ist wahrscheinlich das Gleiche. Ähm ja. Äh die deutschen Geheimdienste, also welche alle sind, die also BND und Verfassungsschutz?
Und militärische Abschirmdienst.
Und der MAD, alles klar. Sind das schon alle oder gibt's noch irgendwelche, von denen wir nichts wissen?
Äh bis jetzt wissen wir da nichts von.
Mhm.
Ähm ja und zwar nach, also einmal die äh das also vielleicht das man das Ganze mal von vorne erzählt. Das geht zurück auf,
die internationale Liga für Menschenrechte ähm und die haben deren, die haben also Anwälte in ihrem Vorstand Menschenrechtsanwälte, die oder Strafrechtsanwälte, die dann diese ähm,
Strafanzeige formuliert haben. Wird häufig als Klage bezeichnet, aber es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen einer.
Meinst du, das geht auf die zurück? Also da kommt die Initiative auch.
Auch die Initiative her, also den, den ist da auch, denen gebührt da auch der äh Kredit, ja, die haben dann den sich an den CCC gewendet und gefragt, ob man sich dieser,
ähm Angelegenheit anschließen möchte und das hat dann der äh CCC einmal als äh Organisation und als ähm,
in Form der Person äh konstant zu kurz gemacht, weil man bei äh so strafrechtsklagen wohl auch ähm glaubhaft eine,
äh also seine Betroffenheit äh vertreten muss. Und das ist natürlich bei einer da da, da braucht's dann auch eine wie nennt man das? Natürliche Person.
Mhm. Und da ist dann sozusagen konstante.
Das hat Konzerne gemacht.
Sich für uns alle vor dem Panzer gestellt.
Ja, genau, ähm genau und ähm das also ein längeres Dokument und jetzt wurde natürlich viel gefragt so, ah okay,
Will der CCC oder wollen diese Organisationen, die drei Organisationen, die das machen, jetzt irgendwie ernsthaft, dass die äh,
Die Bundesregierung in Knast geht oder so, ne? Und ähm das waren auch so immer die Fragen der der Journalisten, die dann so gestellt wurden,
Und natürlich würde ich sagen, das noch ein ein weiter Weg bis dahin,
Aber der der entscheidende Punkt ist ja, also der entscheidende Punkt, warum diese Strafanzeige gestellt wurde, ist, dass der Generalbundesanwalt ja bisher sich immer hingestellt hat und ähm anfangs ja sogar gesagt hat, er sieht noch nicht mal einen Anfangsverdacht, um überhaupt,
Ermittlungen aufzunehmen. Also der hat noch nicht einmal ermittelt in dieser Angelegenheit. Wir haben hier,
seit wie vielen Monaten läuft jetzt hier dieser dieser Snowden Regen auf uns herab? Es geht irgendwie um tausendfache äh Grundrechtsverletzungen die ganze Zeit und als dann irgendwie Merkel betroffen war, da,
Wurde ja dann offensichtlich ein super Grundrecht verletzt. Da musste dann, da war ja mal kurz äh kurz äh ähm,
Unruhe, ja, aber so wirklich dann hat er ja irgendwann auch offiziell verlautbaren lassen, dass er.
Nicht gedenkt, in dieser Angelegenheit zu ermitteln, da eine äh Verurteilung oder überhaupt ein Verfahren schweren,
diplomatischen Schaden an der Bundesrepublik Deutschland verursachen könnte,
Äh was er ja, was er ja auch darf, aber das heißt, letztendlich, der Generalbundesanwalt schaut sich das alles an und sagt, ja äh.
Also mir fällt da nichts auf.
Fällt da nichts auf, wir haben keinen Hinweis, dass hier irgendwas nicht mit rechten Dingen zuginge. So, das lässt zwei Schlüsse zu. Erstens,
Der die ganze deutsche Bundesregierung hat wirklich Schiss vor,
Den USA, wenn sie sich gegen illegale Spionagetätigkeiten der USA auch nur irgendwie äh äußert,
Geschweige denn dagegen ernsthaft tätig wird.
Vorher.
Oder B.
Das denke ich, ist bei dem Ausmaß an Daten, also insbesondere jetzt für den Immobilien und so, äh eine äh,
Ein Verdacht, der durchaus aufkommen kann, sie helfen mit. Ja, also diese gesamten,
Abkommen, die irgendwie zwischen den Geheimdiensten bestehen, über Datenaustausch und Kooperation, die existieren ja und es wäre jetzt auch nicht,
überraschend oder es wäre zumindest nicht undenkbar, dass auch das eine Quelle für Daten für die NSA ist, die eine Rolle spielt bei den Dingen, die AdWords Note veröffentlicht hat,
Ähm insbesondere, dass da irgendwie über SS sieben hier Mobiltelefone abhören und so innerhalb des Landes, da habe ich mich schon eh immer gefragt
ob das wirklich irgendwie äh nationale Anrufe irgendwie im SS sieben so geroutet werden, dass da andere drankommen können. Da stellen sich ein paar Fragen.
Weil da ist eigentlich eher schon schlank nett.
Da sollte eigentlich eher schlank nett sein. Das kommt halt drauf an, wer da der ist. Das weiß ich nicht so genau. Also es ähm ich.
Also zumindest war das mal reines Standnett und äh das mag an manchen Stellen jetzt aufgeweicht sein.
Genau, da würde man also da stellen sich viele Fragen, denen man auf den Grund gehen kann und äh es geht betrifft ja insbesondere diese Snowdenfolien zeigen ja immer nur, welche Daten sie haben, sie zeigen irgendwie nie,
woher sie die wirklich bekommen. Ja, also beispielsweise weiß bis heute gibt's nur Spekulationen darüber, wie wurde Merkels Handy abgehört. Ja, es gibt irgendwie Antworten von mir, äh wie sie's gemacht haben können,
aber es gibt keinen Beleg dafür, wie sie's wirklich gemacht haben. Vielleicht haben sie auch einen einen Trojaner auf dem Telefon, ja, also es gibt keinen.
Das technische Detail fehlt immer bei diesen Snowden Folien. Und,
Das ist natürlich eigentlich das, was genau dann zu ermitteln ist. Wie kommen die da dran? Aus zwei Gründen ist das zu ermitteln. Erstens, damit sie in Zukunft nicht mehr drankommen und zweitens, damit man eben aufklären kann,
ähm ob wer da kooperiert hat. Vielleicht haben die
die die deutschen Mobilfunkanbieter oder Internetanbieter infiltriert, vielleicht arbeiten die da vielleicht zahlen sie die, vielleicht erpressen sie die, also vielleicht hacken sie die so, ne? Also in wenigen Fällen, also Belger kommen jetzt zum Beispiel, in wenigen Fällen sieht man dann wirklich mal, wie sich's technisch hinbekommen haben
und bei diesen großen Sachen immer nicht. Insofern würden wir uns natürlich wünschen, dass da mal Ermittlungen aufgenommen werden, auf das,
Aufklärung auf uns herabregne und wir Erkenntnisgewinn haben und Schutz,
uns schützen können, ja, dass dass sich an dieser Situation überhaupt etwas ändert. Und dafür ist.
Welche Möglichkeit, ich freue mich gerade, welche welche Möglichkeiten hat eigentlich der Bundesstaatsanwalt äh an die geheimen Verträge und Abkommen und äh.
Ja, Absprachen heranzukommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der wirklich an diese Abkommen dran muss. Also die Frage ist doch, also ich weiß nicht, ob er an ein Abkommen dran muss. Es ist auch nicht meine Aufgabe, seine Arbeit zu machen. Aber dass er sich hinstellt und sagt, äh ich.
Verdacht, ja ja also war was.
Sehe noch nicht mal einen Verdacht, dass es halt nicht haltbarer Zustand. Ja, wie Snowden.
Ja. Was denn?
So und das ist ein nicht haltbarer Zustand und daher auch diese Strafanzeige,
Und das ist auch das Ziel dieser Strafanzeige, dass überhaupt einmal Ermittlungen aufgenommen werden. Ich halte das noch nicht mal für unwahrscheinlich, dass ähm da auch diese angesprochenen Straftatbestände äh,
in Teilen erfüllt sind von den ähm von den jeweiligen Diensten, beziehungsweise von der Bundesregierung, wie sie sich da verhält, ja?
Ähm aber natürlich ist es illusorisch, äh dass da irgendwie eine nennenswerte Konsequenz draus äh kommen sollte, zumindest wenn man sich zu
wenn man zugrunde liegt, was in den letzten sechs Monaten passiert ist, also ein Generalbundesanwalt, der sich irgendwie über Monate hinstellt und sagt, ich sehe nichts
und eine Bundesregierung, die äh sich irgendwie auch den größten Teil der Zeit hinstellt und sagt, na ja, wir wollen mal hier nicht, dass äh transatlantische Verhältnis äh belasten,
Da wird jetzt kein kein entscheidender Umschwung mehr stattfinden, ne. Aber interessant ist halt auch, wenn diese wenn dieser Strafantrag zurückgewiesen wird, ja, also dann dann muss er das begründen,
Und das fände ich auch mal witzig. Also so die Antwort äh.
Warum denn da jetzt nichts zu tun sei.
Ich ich habe da jetzt, wir haben da jetzt mal nix gemacht, weil das wäre auch äh die Antwort würde ich auch gerne mal sehen,
Ja und das ist die äh das ist diese Aktion des CCC. Die geht natürlich auch noch weiter. Also ich meine.
Hatte auf jeden Fall, also eins kann man ja schon mal festhalten, das hat,
echt Welle gemacht, als es war wirklich, ich meine, das zeigt sich nicht nur daran, dass äh Russia Today äh darüber berichtet, aber das ist natürlich schon also hat schon echt Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt die Aktion, so.
Die hat äh absolute.
Es hat schon so einiges Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt, ohne dass irgendetwas,
irgendeine Folge gehabt hat, zumindest hat man so den Eindruck, dass es äh keine Folge gehabt hat,
Aber es wird jetzt sehr interessant zu sehen, wie jetzt äh die Reaktion ist, wenn eben auf einer formalen Ebene einmal da vorgegangen wird und man quasi es nicht nur über die Presse versucht, was ja allein offensichtlich nicht ausreichend tut.
Also äh natürlich, es ist auch eine also diese Aktion jetzt,
Ich kann ja, also da ich ja mittelbar daran beteiligt bin, als Mitglied des CCC und als jemand, der das jetzt öffentlich viel vertreten hat, ähm,
will ich da jetzt nicht zu viel eigen Lob irgendwie aussprechen für diese Aktion, aber ich denke, dass das Wichtige ist, auch diese Rückbesinnung auf ähm.
Darauf, was hier eigentlich so die rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien sind. Darauf, was wir hier äh in unserem Grundgesetz stehen haben, darauf,
was was irgendwie unser ähm das Staats- oder das Regierungsprinzip ist,
auf das wir uns hier geeinigt haben, das Herrschaftssystem, Demokratie. So und welche Rechte wir darin haben und welche Rechte wir darin brauchen. Und dass das alles äh in eine sehr, sehr äh dunkle Zukunft weist und alles sehr, sehr übel,
in üblem Ausmaß verletzt wird. Und ich denke das ist auch
Einer der Gründe, warum das so eine entscheidende, warum das so so von den Medien auch aufgegriffen wurde, zu erkennen, jo, stimmt. Das ist nicht nur alles Scheiße, sondern das vertritt was das verstößt auch gegen irgendwie das, was wir uns irgendwann mal hier vereinbart haben für uns.
Ja. Ähm mir fällt in dem Zusammenhang auch wieder ein Vortrag äh des Kongresses auf, der offiziell leider nicht aufgezeichnet wurde, von dem aber trotzdem offensichtlich Stream-Mitschnitte.
Ja, das ist doof gelaufen, der äh du meinst den Vortrag von äh Professor ja, der hatte ähm,
und das wurde es irgendwie unterm Tisch gefallen. Das heißt, er wurde,
seinen Willen veröffentlicht und wurde dann auch äh mit Mustern von mit unschönen Mitteln wieder auch aus YouTube entfernt werden,
War einer der im Ablauf des des dreißig C drei,
Ich mein ist geduldig, findet man bestimmt.
Ja, ich äh hab's gefunden und hatte dann auch die Gelegenheit, da mal wieder reinzuhören und das war ja dann schon ein sehr interessanter Einblick, äh wo ja de facto im Prinzip von ihm, weiß nicht, hast du den auch gesehen.
Den gesehen, ja ich war dort.
Ja, wo er im Wesentlichen eigentlich zusammengefasst wurde, dass wir seit Gründung der Bundesrepublik bis in die heutige Zeit hinein davon ausgehen können, dass halt einfach oder wo zum wo vor allem auch
belegt äh ist für die Vergangenheit, wo wir heute noch davon ausgehen können, dass einfach Absprachen äh
mit den ehemaligen Siegermächten äh bestehen die ihn einfach weitgehend Zugriff auf diese staatliche Kommunikationsinfrastruktur schlicht erlauben
und ich meine das natürlich dann, wenn man das jetzt einfach mal heranzieht und dann äh sagt man
Okay, wir regen jetzt alle darüber auf, dass die USA hier irgendwie alles überwacht. So, muss man sich natürlich nicht groß wundern, wenn man irgendwie über fünfzig Jahre äh explizit diese Erlaubnis dafür gegeben hat, nur wird es irgendwie nicht thematisiert
So, wenn man aber jetzt einem Bundesstaatsanwalt, dass sozusagen nochmal in dem Kontext äh vorlegt und sagt,
ja äh guck mal, kann es sein, dass es hier ein Dokument gibt, was du nicht kennst oder zumindest offiziell,
nicht kennst oder nicht kennen solltest oder ich weiß nicht ganz genau finde geheim gehaltene Verträge auf Staatsebene ohnehin höchstgradig,
Problematisch. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir dabei geht, aber ich äh da da da schaltet bei mir irgendwas ab. Ja, bitte hallo irgendwie das Fundament des Staates.
Passiert doof oder was heißt passiert auf, aber enthält ja, geheime Komponenten, kann ja wohl nicht sein.
Ja, absolut. Absolut.
Also vielleicht ist ja die Bundesrepublik auch ungültig, ja. War einfach äh.
Fängst du jetzt an mit den Spezialisten, die immer sagen, dass alles hier noch deutsches Reich oder was?
Aber es gab mal diese schöne Titantik äh Schlagzeile. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch zum Wiedervereinigung?
Genscher gedurft oder sowas, ne.
Wiedervereinigung äh ungültig. Äh Kohl war gedopet, dazu muss man völlig diviööses Bild von ihm. Ja.
Ja, also geheim.
War ja Adenauer schon gedopt.
Und das Schöne ist ja, diese also,
Ich habe das auch in der in dem mal angesprochen. Die erste Reaktion sollte man auch nicht vergessen. Die erste Reaktion auf diese Snowne Enthüllung war äh irgendwie gut Friedrich geht rüber. Äh okay, das äh ist geschenkt. Und dann aber,
dass die deutschen Geheimdienstchefs rübergegangen sind und mit den NSA gesprochen haben. Nicht die Regierung miteinander, die Geheimdienste miteinander haben sich geeinigt und dann kamen sie zurück und haben gesagt, wir machen No-Spy-Abkommen. Das sind inzwischen erledigt. Ja, das ist wieder vom Tisch.
Man könnte man könnte jetzt unterstellen, ja, dass so sich tatsächlich die höchsten Gremien der Bundesrepublik mit diesem Fall auseinandergesetzt haben.
Könnte man unterstellen, aber nicht belegen. Widerspricht auch keiner, will halt keine drüber reden.
Wir müssen auch noch verlinken, es gab einen sehr schönen Auftritt äh oder sehr schönen Mitschnitt der Heute-Show. Die sind dann, die haben dann dann den äh ähm Thomas de Maizire und den Hans-Georg Maaßen muss das, glaube ich, gewesen sein. Heißt, Herr Hans-Georg, ja, ne?
Glaube ja.
Ähm,
befragt haben so, ne, wie sie sich jetzt fühlen, sich mit einem Bein im Knast und äh ja, da gab's dann natürlich sehr sufficisante Antworten von dem ähm von dem Thomas de Maizire, der ähm.
Dann irgendwie so sagte, ja äh,
Das stimmt, jeder kann ja in Deutschland Strafanzeigen stellen, das äh wäre da jetzt nicht beunruhigt, dass er äh irgendwie mit irgendeiner Strafe konfrontiert wird. Ähm ist eine ist eine korrekte Einschätzung. Die Strafe ist ihm noch sehr fern,
Aber äh diese dieser Süphisanz zeigt sich ja auch, äh da bildet sich ja viel drin ab. Und wie gesagt, die Strafe sollte ihm nicht so fern sein,
wie sie jetzt in der realistischen Einschätzung gerade ist. Und ich denke, das zu zeigen, ja, dass da der der Gesetzbruch und der Grundrechtsbruch offenkundig ist und wie darauf reagiert wird, das ist das, was ähm,
Was diese Aktion auf jeden Fall macht und ich würde mir natürlich sehr wünschen, dass der äh dass der Effekt ist, dass wir äh also dass es auch wirklich etwas zur Verbesserung der Welt beiträgt. Bisher hat's nur Aufsehen errig und,
War eine schöne Collage. Aber ich würde mir natürlich sehr wünschen, dass der Generalbundesanwalt jetzt auch Ermittlungen aufnimmt.
Und was hat er getan?
Er tut's, er tut es, hat natürlich überhaupt nichts damit zu tun, dass jetzt diese Strafanzeige vorliegt. Aber der Generalbundesanwalt darf jetzt ermitteln, die Bundesregierung hat keine Einwände mehr. Ja.
Oh. Ja. Also ihnen ist nichts mehr eingefallen, was sie jetzt noch dagegen vorbringen können.
Ja, allerdings so, das war eine, waren bis jetzt nur eine äh Kurzmeldung, ähm wo gesagt wird, der die Generalbundesanwaltschaft wird und will ein Verfahren zur NSA-Affäre einleiten, aber da geht's wohl eher so um die Überwachung von Merkels Handy.
Das wäre dann eben aber auch der Paragraph äh zweihundert hm,
Nee, neunundneunzig STGB, verbotene Geheimdienstliche Agententätigkeit,
beziehungsweise Paragraphen zweihunderteins STGB Verletzung des persönlichen Lebens und Geheimbereiches, die da betroffen wären. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, ob er sich nur auf diese äh Handyabhöraktion errichten wird.
Oder auch auf mehr. Und da gibt's einen sehr schönen, eine sehr wichtige Anmerkung, die immer, wenn jemand von Merkels Handy anfängt zu reden, gemacht werden muss, bitte, liebe Hörerinnen, macht das auch in eurem Privatgesprächen. Der Skandal ist nicht,
ein Regierungsoberhaupt abgehört wurde. Der das ist Gang und gäbe und das muss ein Regierungsoberhaupt wissen,
dass es vermutlich, wenn es irgendwie möglich ist, abgehört wird, weil sich das für eine ganze Menge Staaten dieser Erde,
sehr bezahlt macht diese Person abzuhören. Der Skandal ist, dass wir alle abgehört werden. Nicht Angela Merkel,
Angela Merkel ist nur in alle mit drin,
und deshalb äh auch betroffen und äh die Frage ist, wenn man sagt, alle, dann äh ist es eben sehr erstaunlich, ähm dass sich dann Personen wundern, ach auch Merkel, auch Gerhard Schröder.
Auch Gerhard Schröder.
Jetzt sag nicht auch noch den äh den Bundesinnenminister. Dann wäre ich ja jetzt wirklich verrückt. Ne, also dass der Skandal ist ein anderer.
Diese Meldung finde ich ja geil irgendwie auf der Süddeutschen. Verstehe ich da gerade irgendwas nicht. Bundesregierung billigt Ermittlungen. Also ich meine
Ist das überhaupt relevant, ob die das jetzt billigt oder nicht? Bundesanwaltschaft äh ist doch irgendwie beim Bundesgerichtshof äh angesiedelt, bis Teil sozusagen der.
Also der, sie können, sie können das tun, also ähm die Strafprozessordnung sieht vor, dass die Bundesregierung äh eingreifen kann, wenn sie schwere außenpolitische Schäden für Deutschland befürchtet.
Das wäre also genau dieser dieser Punkt.
Aber das haben sie jetzt mal ausnahmsweise mal nicht gemacht.
Da ist eben genau die Frage, ob sie es,
Also das kommt jetzt natürlich also ich meine Vermutung ist, der gute Herr Range, Generalbundesanwalt sitzt da jetzt in einem Zimmer und spricht irgendwie mit Frau Merkel und Herrn de Maizire.
Vielleicht noch mit dem Justizminister Heiko Maas, aber ich glaube nicht, dass der äh dass der zu sowas eingeladen wird im Moment. Der hat ja erstmal ein bisschen verkackt. Bei äh bei den bei Herrn de Maizire. Ähm.
Und dann werden die sich überlegen, okay, was können wir machen, was können wir nicht machen. Die wollen sich natürlich nicht.
Die wollen sich natürlich nicht.
Öffentliche Blöße geben, dass jetzt der Range mit irgendwas vorprescht und dann der äh dann irgendwie äh de Maizire oder so sagen muss,
lass mal bitte,
Das werden sie sich öffentlich, wahrscheinlich nicht, ähm, geben wollen. Also, so klug würde ich sie grade noch einschätzen, dass sie das vorher absprechen und da nicht irgendwie, äh,
Zwietracht zwischen ähm zwischen diesen beiden Verfassungsorganen,
Oder ist, ist der, ist der Generalbundesanwalt, ist wahrscheinlich kein Verfassungsorgan. Nee, ist Quatsch. Aber diesen beiden hohen äh Einrichtungen der der äh Bundesrepublik da öffentlich äh,
zu verkünden.
Na gut, wir werden sehen. Äh.
Gerichtshof ist wahrscheinlich dann der Verfassungsorgan.
Dabei rauskommt,
Ja, also das ist sicherlich jetzt nicht alles vollständig unerwähnt, ich weiß es nicht, bin eher nahe und bin schon gar kein Verfassungsexperte,
Wir halten einfach nur fest, Strafanzeige wurde gestellt. Äh man muss jetzt mal gucken, inwieweit das äh äh wirklich irgendwas zur Folge hat, aber zumindest,
ähm wird weiter drüber gesprungen.
An der Stelle noch äh darf nicht unerwähnt bleiben. Es gibt noch ein weiteres Verfahren, das die äh Konstanze,
für den CCC gerade oder ja, das macht sie, glaube ich, sogar als Einzelperson. Ähm,
Aber natürlich mit dem CCC im im als Unterstützung im Hintergrund. Und zwar ist das die Beschwerde am äh europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrecht. Die haben wir hier auch schon erwähnt und da geht's um das Verfahren gegen den GCAQ.
Mhm.
Ähm dass also da die Praxen des GCHQ äh Rechtsgrundsätze der äh,
Europäischen Gemeinschaft verletzen. Und das sind also Big Brother Watch, die Open Rides Group äh eine britische Schriftstellervereinigung und äh konstante Kurz als Einzelperson
in ihrer Rolle als Sprecherin des CC, ähm die also diese Beschwerde äh angeraumt haben,
dann hat das äh Gericht ein Paar Voruntersuchungen äh äh gemacht und dann ein Schnellverfahren eingeleitet. Das heißt, ähm,
bis zum zweiten Mai muss die äh britische Regierung antworten auf die Vorwürfe,
Und dann soll relativ bald ein äh ein Urteil gesprochen werden. Das heißt,
an dieser zweiten Front könnte es also sein, dass bei diesem Verfahren vom EGMR die Praxen des äh GCAge Q eben da nochmal abgeurteilt werden.
Insofern diese beiden Verfahren sind auch äh sind eben zu trennen, auch wenn sie beide sehr eng mit dem ähm,
CCC verbunden sind durch die Person Konstanze und auch beide sich gegen äh GCHQ,
in Teilen richten, nur am EGMR eben folgt nur gegen und ähm,
äh bei die Strafanzeige in Deutschland eben ähm,
auch gegen GCHQ, wobei natürlich dann mit äh Angela Merkel da prominentere Figuren drin sind, auf die sich dann natürlich auch die mediale Aufmerksamkeit.
Fokussiert hat.
Ja, das äh bringt uns zu unserer populärsten Kategorie, ja, was ja irgendwie das Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung zum Beispiel komplett auf Platz zwei verdrängt hat, mindestens.
Ja, wir haben ja immer wieder neue äh neue,
Erkenntnisse und auch immer solche unglaubliche Klopfer dabei. Die geilste Meldung war ja nicht nur Angela Merkel wurde abgehört. Nein,
Nein, sogar auch der große.
Nein. Oh.
Unfassbar, ja, aber hätte es gedacht, äh eine geile Meldung, vor allem mit,
sein Telefon wurde abgehört und dann gab's dann so schnell äh in der Folge,
der Berichterstattung hatte gar nicht ein Telefon, was sein Telefon war, also man ist ja mittlerweile schon so drauf fixiert, dass jeder Mann und jeder Frau heutzutage ein eigenes Telefon hat im Sinne von einem Mobiltelefon,
Gerhard fand Mobiltelefone irgendwie ein bisschen uncool,
oder vielleicht Tante auch sich zu uncool für ein Mobiltelefon, wir wissen's nicht so ganz genau. Äh es gab da wohl ein Mobiltelefon in seiner Umgebung, was ihm dann von Sicherheitsbeamten im Zweifelsfall auch mal gereicht wurde.
Was ist, ja? Also ich meine, äh coole Sicherheitsmaßnahme der Sicherheitsbedienstete, der die ganze Zeit neben dir sitzt, hält das Telefon, ja, aber okay.
Immerhin war er jetzt nicht so ein Typ, der irgendwie den ganzen Tag mit einem Mobiltelefon in der Hosentasche.
Richtig, die Merke, die twittert ja auch oder SME, die simst ja, Merkel simpst, Merkel Sim.
Ja so ein Twitter Presi haben wir noch nicht, ne?
Die Merkel Sims. Ähm ja, Schröder haben sie auch abgehört, unglaublich, oder? Wer hätte das gedacht? Ja.
Ich meine, man kann sogar davon ausgehen, dass diese komplette äh in in den engeren Fokus neben der Bundesrepublik Deutschland letzten Endes auch äh an ihm hing.
Das äh wurde ja auch aus einigen Berichten nochmal hm wie soll ich sagen, deutlich,
Wir erinnern uns äh ist halt eigentlich jetzt der Kanzler gewesen, der das erste Mal so ein bisschen die Trauter hatte, sich äh nach langer ähm,
Gefolgschaftsnormalität den USA ein wenig die Stirn zu bieten damals, als die USA halt beschlossen hat oder vorhatte. Ähm zu beschließen, den Irak-Krieg anzuzetteln und,
mit Joschka Fischer,
waren war Schröder halt äh der Meinung, dass das mal eine Schnapsidee war. Sicherlich eine der vertretbareren äh politischen Positionen, die äh ja so in seiner Amtszeit äh gebracht hat.
Und ähm ja, daraufhin war die Amerikaner auf die Deutschen nicht mehr so gut zu sprechen.
Obwohl die Deutschen ja dann doch da irgendwie alle mögliche Hilfe geleistet haben, ne?
Jahr im Nachgang konnte man sich natürlich dann nicht so ganz entziehen. Es war mehr so eine, ja jetzt wo er jetzt sowieso schon da war, dann können wir ja auch mal wieder eine Schule bauen und so. Das.
Nee, das war doch auch aktive Hilfe irgendwie, war das denn? Überwachung Sachen und.
Ich glaube, diese AVAC äh äh problematisch.
Überflugsrechte und was ja nicht.
Überflussrichter, ich klar, also ich meine, das ist natürlich viel von Frankfurt aus gestartet ist in diesem Krieg, ist klar, so.
Ja, aber einen Krieg nicht zu unterstützen, heißt halt auch zu sagen, ja, unser Flughafen hat heute irgendwie Pause.
Sagen wir mal, es war der Anflug von wir sind nicht hundertprozentig dabei,
und äh hätte hätte Schröder jetzt so dicht gemacht, dass er sagt äh ja nee, es darf ja auch kein äh amerikanisches Flugzeug mehr starten, was ja de facto bedeutet hätte.
Dann werden die wahrscheinlich gekommen und nicht gelandet. Na ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das bedeutet hätte, aber das wäre dann wahrscheinlich.
Hätten sie beide Handys von ihm abgehört.
Yeah,
Also, das das wäre wahrscheinlich ein Eklat gewesen in einem in einer Dimension, wie äh ihn äh Merkel nur fürchten kann. Ähm
Damit ist ja auch nicht genug getan. Die äh Bundesrepublik ist natürlich über die NATO ohnehin ein militärisches System eingebettet und betreibt da unter Umständen viel äh nicht nur unter Umständen, sondern
Unter anderem
diese AWAX-Flugzeuge und so weiter, die ja dann auch aufklärerisch tätig waren, indem sie sich dann eben auch nicht so ohne Weiteres entziehen können. Also es war halt alles irgendwie,
Wenn man jetzt mit mit der
pazifistischen äh Fehler drauf gezeigt hätte, wenn man gesagt hätte, oh, das war aber jetzt hier nicht komplett kriegsfrei, ja. Eure Aktivität, so, klar, aber nichtsdestotrotz haben sie sich dagegen äh gestellt. Ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht bewerten. Ist einfach nur so, so war's.
Und ähm,
Das hat sicherlich dazu beigetragen, dass die USA noch mehr, als es vielleicht bisher schon der Fall war. So die Brau gelupft hat und gesagt hat, so die Jungs, da die schauen wir uns mal ein bisschen genauer an.
Na ja.
Ist aber doch trotzdem nicht zu entschuldigen, oder? Also.
Dass es jetzt hier Abhörmaßnahmen.
Ist das jetzt, ist das jetzt ist das jetzt okay? Also finden wir das okay.
Ich finde jetzt auch diese Meldung ein bisschen unklar. Ich meine, was heißt jetzt Schröder, wurde abgehört. Das wird halt alles abgehört und äh natürlich,
man weiß ja wahrscheinlich auch vorher überhaupt gar nicht, wen man eigentlich abhört. Es werden halt einfach alle Leitungen irgendwie angezapft, die sich irgendwie greifen lassen.
Die werden jetzt den Schröder nicht versehentlich abgehört haben.
Nö, die werden schon irgendwie versucht haben. Ich meine, die ist ja auch nicht so, dass ich jetzt nur eine einzige Person,
abhören, einen Geheimdienst versucht natürlich, das komplette politische System zu dekodieren. Da gehören alle Zuträger, Berater, äh zweite, dritte, vierte, fünfte Beamtenebene, dazu komplette Ministerien,
alles will man haben. Ist einfach so.
Genau und das kostet auch verhältnismäßig wenig, wenn man sich überlegt, welchen strategischen Vorteil man dadurch hat und äh das machen ja anderen Länder genauso, da kommen wir gleich nochmal zu. Ähm also Schröder wurde abgehört. Moment, ich muss mal kurz husten. Vielleicht möchtest du das nächste Thema schon mal.
Ja, also man kann ja hier äh auf jeden Fall auch nochmal in die andere Richtung schauen, was es auch noch bei äh Snowden gab, war eine Meldung, dass GCHQ äh so gegen die ein oder andere Maßnahme äh äh fährt, da
aber nicht so ganz genau, wie das gelaufen ist, was was ist da gewesen.
GCATQ-Folien sind dann aufgetaucht aus dem Snowdenfundus. Und da geht's um, was offensichtlich eine Präsentation, wie
wie das GCHQ gegen vorgegangen ist. Hast du das gar nicht mitbekommen.
Nee, ich habe das überhaupt nicht mitbekommen. Ich stehe so ein bisschen im.
Das war schön, da haben sie äh ich, da muss ich jetzt mal kurz noch was rausholen. Da haben sie äh eine äh Dedos-Attacke gegen gemacht, weil äh um die ähm aus einem ähm,
um die Leute da irgendwie außer Gefecht zu setzen, ja? Das waren also.
Gegen die Gruppe, die einen wesentlichen deshalb verfolgt wird, weil sie Detox-Attacken machen, machen sie Detox-Attacken? Ja. Oh.
Das ist ja ganz okay. Ich meine, die ähm USA gehen da gehen gegen äh Terroristen vor, weil sie sich nicht an rechtsstaatliche Prinzipien halten wollen und foltern die dann,
Also es hat eigentlich Konsequenz, dass wenn du dann gegen Leute die das machen, dann Dedos machst.
Mhm. So diese Todesstraf-Mentalität.
Wenn du dich nicht an, wenn du dich nicht an unsere Regeln hättest, brauchen wir uns auch nicht mehr dran zu halten. Ist eigentlich total geil, ne? Wir haben Regeln, ja? Aber wenn du dich dran hältst, dann gelten die auch nicht für dich.
Eigentlich geil. Ja.
Ähm jetzt warte mal ganz kurz, das ist jetzt total blöd, dass ich das hier gerade gar nicht finde. Also ich würde jetzt gerne diese Folie aufmachen. Ähm meine Güte.
Einfach nur ausgedacht.
Nein, habe ich nicht. Es ist jetzt wirklich blöd, dass ich den Link da gerade nicht in der äh in der Sammlung habe.
Ja, das ist blöd. Jetzt klappt es wieder keiner, was.
Nein, nein, nein, ich, ich, ich klick, ich muss nur noch kurz den Link dazu äh,
Hinzufügen, da ist er auch schon. So, da haben wir also eine eine äh eine Folie,
Wo sie also sagen, okay, wir haben Intelligence genutzt äh und zwar
sagen sie dann so, welche Gruppen gibt's da so? Syrien, Cyber-Army und so weiter und ihre Techniken, die sie, die sie angewendet haben, sind Dedos, Datendiebstahl, SQL Injections und Social Engineerings. Also die haben einen quasi,
mit den gleichen Mitteln,
Ein Kampf gegen äh diese Leute geführt. Und haben sich sogar äh eines eines äh Bot Netz bemächtigt, also Botnetz,
Es gibt im Prinzip der der Markt äh in Anführungszeichen eine oder eine der eines der Geschäftsmodelle auf dem Schwarzmarkt des Internets ist, dass Menschen, die in der Lage sind, ähm.
Botnet zu schreiben oder ein Botnett zu ähm,
zu betreiben, dieses dann vermieden. Ja, also man man infiziert viele äh man infiziert möglichst viele Rechner mit einer Software, die möglichst große Kontrolle über diese Rechner ermöglicht und ähm,
bietet dann diese Rechner an,
Ja und da wird dann, die können dann Spam verschicken, die können Dedosangriffe machen und man vermietet diese Bot Nets dann eben
zum Stundenpreis oder zum äh Gigabit-Preis, äh wie je nachdem äh welchen welchen Zweck, der der Kunde mitverfolgen möchte,
Und das ist natürlich so, dass absolut ähm.
Also ich meine, äh man kann sich ja wenig Asozialeres vorstellen als Rechner zu hacken und zu kompromitieren,
Das mit dem Ziel zu tun, diese dann an andere zu vermieten, ja. Also du hast noch nicht einmal, willst du da Daten rauskratzen, noch nicht einmal verfolgst du ein Ziel? Nein. Du willst einfach nur diese Rechner,
an andere vermieten, die damit dann irgendwie ähm,
mehr oder weniger elegante, kriminelle äh Machenschaften verfolgen. Also es ist schon eine ziemlich asoziale äh,
Ziemlich asoziale Sache so nett zu betreiben und zu vermieden.
Ja, ich will jetzt nicht gleich den Vergleich mit Waffenhandel äh rausziehen, aber.
Waffenhandel, finde ich, ist da auch ist ja kein guter Vergleich.
Zumindest wenn man irgendwie so Autos klaut, nur um sie dann irgendwelchen Bankräubern zur Verfügung zu stellen. Ja okay, also alle, alle Vergleiche mit der realen Welt, wissen wir, na.
Ein Vergleich, aber ich meine, das sind Leute, die hacken deinen Computer, nur damit andere damit irgendwie Scheiße bauen können, damit sie die an andere vermieten können. Also viel weniger ähm.
Weniger Respekt für irgendwie Menschen kann man und und in ihre Rechensysteme kann man glaube ich kaum auf.
Ja, da zeigt sich natürlich auch wieder sehr schön, was sich ja auch durch die ganze Zeit durch diese Geschichte äh zieht, dass einfach die Staaten einfach durch diese Ausnutzung von Unsicherheiten, ja, offensichtlich auch gar kein Interesse daran haben, dass diese Unsicherheiten verschwinden.
Genau, ich wollte ganz kurz nur sagen, was sie gemacht haben, ist, sich mit genau einem solchen Händler eingelassen,
und dessen Dienste in äh in Anspruch genommen haben. Das heißt, sie haben einen Kriminellen äh beauftragt und sich dort einen ähm.
Aha. Versterben.
Ja, also das ist auch nicht besonders cool. Na ja, dann haben sie irgendwie andere Leute, dann zeigen sie ein paar Erfolge, wie sie Menschen identifiziert haben, die dann jetzt auch im Knast sitzen,
Ja? Schon interessant, dass sie das machen, ja? Also ich meine,
es ist anderseits, wenn man sich in solchen in an solchen Aktionen beteiligt, insbesondere wenn's dann ans Hecken geht, natürlich davon auszugehen, dass man's da auch mit entsprechenden Gegnern zu tun hat.
Die werden ne, also wenn's dann irgendwie an an größere hier Identitätsdiebstahl geht oder so, um wirklich um kriminelle.
Oder nicht kriminelle, aber um strafbare Hacks. Ja
dann hast du es natürlich auch mit Leuten zu tun, die da gegen dich ermitteln und ist natürlich auch sehr spannend. Also ich weiß noch ziemlich genau, als diese ganze Enormes Sache losging. Ich war da jetzt nie so der äh ich war da jetzt nie so begeistert von, dass das jetzt irgendwie die besonders geniale Sache war.
Ihre.
Wahrlich nicht.
Ähm
insbesondere als dann die Payment-Blockade auf Wiki Leaks ging, wo sie dann da irgendwie äh äh Angriffe auf ähm Visa und Mastercard gemacht haben und so. Da war ich jetzt nicht unbedingt der der absolute äh Fürsprecher
Ja, das hat auch ähm letztendlich, glaube ich, der Sache nicht gut getan. Was was da gemacht wurde. Aber äh man muss auch anerkennen, das waren halt ähm,
Im Prinzip Massendemonstration von Menschen so und das waren jetzt keine
Kriminellen, das waren auch keine Hacker, ja? Zumindest der größte Teil von diesen Leuten. Und ähm das kann man schon, kann man jetzt sagen, dass keine besonders tolle Sache, aber das ist jetzt auch nicht irgendwie besonders.
Besonders kritisch.
Das haben aber die, das haben aber natürlich Gerichte anders gesehen. Also ich hab's immer so ein bisschen kindisch abgetan und dieses Getue, was da irgendwie mit einherging und so. Und wir sind jetzt irgendwie die wir müssen jetzt hier vorsichtig sein. Richtig cool wurd's eigentlich erst mit,
die dann irgendwie wirklich auch mal gehackt haben,
Sachen rausgehauen haben. Das wird jetzt auch also kann man dann moralisch auch äh stark in äh in Frage stellen, was sie gemacht haben. Ähm,
weil sie ja irgendwie überall Daten rausgekratzt haben und irgendwo einfach rausgehauen haben und weitergemacht haben und dann ja auch, jetzt grade unter drakonischen äh äh Strafmaß leiden, ne? Oder gerade mit dem FBI kooperieren, wie der gute Hector, Monfigur. Wir haben das vor
vielen, vielen Wochen.
Mir das hier schon mal.
Hier schon mal besprochen. Auf jeden Fall fand ich,
Worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist, als dieser ganze enorme Miskram losging und die dann irgendwie meinten, da so, ja und wir sind jetzt hier geheim und Pieper, wo wir arbeiten hier im Untergrund und so, das habe ich eigentlich immer so ein bisschen belächelt.
Dass ich so dachte, ja okay, da sind jetzt irgendwie ein paar Teenager, die sitzen da jetzt und äh nutzen irgendwelche Open Source äh Deder Software, um mal irgendwie eine eine Seite platt zu machen und äh,
sich dann cool vor, ja? Auch dieser eine Teenager, ich habe den Namen jetzt ganz vergessen, der dann da irgendwie vor Gericht auftrat, top piarry war sein ähm sein,
Händel. Ich weiß nicht, wie sein richtiger Name war, habe ich vergessen. Die dann da irgendwie sich irgendwie wie die wie die absoluten ähm,
Robin Hoodstar aufgeführt haben so, ne? Aber so am Ende ja zwei Jahre später hörst du, ja okay,
War irgendwie,
massiv damit beschäftigt eure Infrastruktur auszuforschen, euch anzugreifen, euch in den Knast zu bringen, Beweise gegen euch zu sammeln. So, ihr hattet es einfach mal mit den Geheimdiensten zu tun. Als eine kleine Gruppe von
oder als eine mittelgroße Bewegung von Teenagern, die mal einen Tag lang eine Webseite platt gemacht haben.
Ja
total überzogen. Ich denke, das muss man halt auch sehen. Ich meine, so ich sehe das genauso wie du mit Anonymus und so weiter, dass das alles zwar verständlich, nachvollziehbar war, auch sehr schön, eigentlich so ein Symptom gezeigt hat, nämlich so dass ein Prinzip da schon ein
ein großer Dissens mit dem mit den Herrschenden ähm Zuständen und den tatsächlichen Vorfällen,
existierte bei vielen Leuten, die jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt wirklich die technische Möglichkeiten hatten oder auch die politischen Einflussmöglichkeiten nicht hatten. Und dann einfach,
auf die ihnen naheliegendste Methode einfach mitprotestiert haben. Das ist so ein bisschen so, als ob du schon den ersten Mob auf der Straße siehst und du schließt dich dem einfach an und dann wirfst du halt auch irgendwas gegens Fenster.
Weil das einfach in dem Moment die einzige äh oder naheliegendste Möglichkeit ist,
deinem Dissens da äh Ausdruck zu verleihen, auch wenn das dann nicht unbedingt immer die die klügste Maßnahme ist.
Ich weiß es noch nicht mal, also ich, ich, wie gesagt, ich schäle im Armbivalent gegenüber, aber Fakt ist, also ich denke, dass bei den enormen Missaktionen,
häufig die Presseberichterstattung für die Sache, die man verfolgt hat, nicht positiv war. Also.
Ne, Wiki Leaks kriegt, Wiki Leaks wird von der Bezahlung abgeschlossen, drei Tage später da was steht in den Medien ähm.
Hackerhorden fallen über die Infrastruktur, ja.
Mastercard Lahm, ja? So und wo dann jeder denkt, oh mein Gott, Mastercut wurde gehackt. Ich wurde, ich bin betroffen, meine Kreditkarte äh ist in Gefahr vor Hackern, was soll ich mit diesem.
Business kann kein Payment mehr abwickeln, was habe ich damit zu tun?
Andererseits muss es natürlich irgendwie ein dreizehnjähriger, der sich gerade die Leuk runtergeladen hat und irgendwie mit seinem mit seinem kleinen DSL-Anschluss da irgendwie ein äh ein millionstel zu diesem ähm,
milliardenstel zu dieser äh Dedosattacke beigetragen hat, kann natürlich sich da sicherlich auch mal äh besonders stolz drauf finden. Auf jeden Fall, Fakt ist.
Das sind jetzt nicht die großen Feinde des Staates.
Ich denke, da könnten wir uns einig sein oder die sind im Moment Wahnsinn, die zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine nennenswerte ähm.
Große Gefahr für diesen Staat. So. Wäre schön gewesen, wenn sie's mal geworden wären
Hätten wir mal was gesehen, aber.
Jeden Fall verfolgt worden, als wären sie.
Sie sind aber drakonisch verfolgt worden. Was natürlich auch also,
Das hier jetzt von der von der vor Gericht keinerlei äh Gnade erwarten würde, war klar, weil man an denen wie immer
ein Exempel statuieren muss, ja? Also die ersten, die losgehen und irgendwie da die die große Konzerne dieser Welt dedossen müssen halt, an denen muss ein Exempel statuiert werden, damit du das jetzt nicht demnächst jeden Tag hast. Und genauso wird ein Muss an Julian Assange, ein Exempel statuiert werden, damit der nächste, der sich sowas traut
ähm irgendwie ähm bisschen länger auf sich warten lässt, so. So läuft der Hase, aber dass da die Geheimdienste drin hängen, ja?
Lässt zwei Schlüsse zu und ich denke, den Schluss würde ich offen lassen. Erster Schluß ist, die Geheimdienste haben echt nichts zu tun und ist ein Beleg dafür, wie sie irgendwie Bürgerbewegungen unterwandern. Ähm Demonstrationen und Aktivistengruppen,
irgendwie bekämpfen und und verhindern, ja?
Und habe also wirklich einfach das, was demokratische Beteiligung ist, spezifisch angreifen.
Unterwandern und kaputtmachen oder man könnte sagen, die haben dermaßen Schiss.
Vor dieser Internetöffentlichkeit, vor dem, was das Netz,
macht das ihnen klar ist, wenn sich einfach mal ein paar Leute wirklich zusammentun. Und sich echt mal ein paar Gedanken darüber machen. Ähm dass es diese internationale Vernetzung, wenn sie es einfach mal,
vernünftig und sicher betreiben,
Inhalt wirklich entgeht. Dass sie das Potential, das der das Potential einer Internetmassenbewegung da erkannt hat,
und korrekt als Gefahr, als große Gefahr für die Stabilität anerkannt hat und entsprechend bekämpft hat, weiß ich noch nicht mal.
Schon so ein bisschen so während den Anfängen äh mäßig einfach.
Na, dass sie einfach das denen einfach klar war, okay, wenn diese äh Nonnemütze jetzt hier sich, wenn die das jetzt richtig machen, dann können wir hier jahrelang große Probleme bekommen. Weiß ich nicht. Also so die beiden, die beiden Möglichkeiten sehe ich da.
Dann haben wir noch,
Schöne Meldung, äh Angriff auf Einzelpersonen. Ähm so ein belgischer Kryptograph wurde irgendwie mit einer gefälschten LinkedIn-Seite,
angegriffen, wo sie irgendwie dessen Daten kommen wollten, an dessen Kommunikation haben sie dann mit diesem System, was auch in Jacobs Vortrag äh,
benannt wurde, ich habe jetzt leider kurz vergessen, wie das hieß. Wo du quasi, wo sie ganz schnell quasi eine eine.
Also wo sie dazwischengrätschen und dir eine andere Webseite ausliefern als die, von der du eigentlich meintest, das Beispiel war, glaube ich, in dem Vortrag Yahoo oder was auch immer und dann äh also die Antworten einfach schneller aus ihrem Netz heraus, als die eigentliche Webseite und damit können sie sich dazwischen schalten.
Und das haben sie äh mit diesem belgischen Kryptographen gemacht, Forscher, an Kryptographie, hat dann halt mal das äh Interesse der Geheimdienste auf sich gezogen.
Und was haben sie denn mit ihm gemacht? Also ich meine, sie haben ihm den Link über LinkedIn äh Chart-Code eingetrichtert oder was?
Ich muss leider sagen, dass ich das nicht mehr so genau für weiter verfolgt habe. Ähm.
Mhm.
Die das das Entscheidende ist an oder das das äh,
Das Entscheidende an dieser Frage ist, dass sie der gute Mann heißt, weißt du, oder wie ist der?
Jeanchaké. Schwieriger Name, ja. Den haben sie halt irgendwie äh,
angegriffen. Also wie immer so, sie haben ihn gehackt, aber dann steht er wieder nicht groß viel drin, ja. Also ist ein emeritierter Professor sogar. Ähm,
den sie da irgendwie gezielt angegriffen haben,
mit einer gefälschten LinkedIn-Seite. Ähm und dann haben sie, ja doch, tatsächlich haben sie ihm halt eine eine Vektor irgendwie auf seinem Rechner installiert.
Okay.
Wunderbar.
Snowden soll aber dann auch mal äh wieder zum Einsatz kommen und nicht immer nur seine Dokumente.
Er hat seine Bereitschaft erklärt gegenüber dem EU-Parlament auszusagen, man ist sich aber noch nicht darüber klar, äh ob das irgendwie mit einer mit einem persönlichen Besuch äh verbunden werden soll
oder äh irgendwie über eine Fernschalte gemacht werden soll. Da gab's ja auch schon vor Wochen dann irgendwie die Debatten im äh,
im Europaparlament oder so. Äh da werden wir sehen, also da da steht, glaube ich, noch viel in den Sternen. Ähm aber es gibt jetzt schon mal die generelle Bereitschaft,
Aber natürlich heißt das so, da wird es jetzt mal interessant. Das ist ja genau das, was äh Christian Ströbele immer anspricht. Der sagt, okay.
Der soll doch bitte kommen, der soll doch bitte als Zeuge vernommen werden.
Weil er hat ja offensichtlich was zu erzählen.
Weil er hat ja offensichtlich was zu erzählen und wenn wir ihn als Zeugen vernehmen, dann könnten wir das doch bei ihm mal genauso machen, wie bei den mehrfachen Mördern aus der Mafia,
denen wir dann einfach ein schönes Weingut irgendwo kaufen, wo sie dann mit einer neuen Identität äh des den Rest ihres Lebens irgendwie,
verbringen können. Ja, also tatsächlich ist das Ströbele ziemlich genau so ähm,
Vertreten bei einer Infoveranstaltung der äh dieser bei dieser Klage der Internet.
Also sozusagen gar nicht mal jetzt nur so die Argumentation mit, er ist ja ein Whistleblower und von daher zu schützen, sondern selbst wenn man jetzt die Argumentation.
Reden von Strafrecht, wir reden von Strafrecht und entsprechende Zeugen in Strafrechtsprozessen können Kronzeugen Regelungen für sich beanspruchen.
Genau, aber ich meine, es übernimmt ja dann sozusagen oder kontert zumindest eben diese diese Gegenaussage, äh also die Behauptung, es würde sich ja bei Snowden um einen Verbrecher handeln,
oder es oder jemand, der in den USA Rechte verletzt hat, auch wenn es ja da keine wirkliche
konkrete Anklage gibt derzeit, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Wie auch immer, also selbst wenn man diese diese Diktion übernimmt, könnte man dann mit der Argumentation immer noch einsteigen und sagen, ja okay, das ist jetzt hier ein totaler Massendatenvergewaltiger, ja, aber äh er
äh ist dann halt einfach unser Kronzeuge und dann.
Also das ist der Punkt ist auch das einzige, wie sie ihm wirklich Schutz gewähren können. Also natürlich ist davon auszugehen, wenn also,
Das betrifft einmal die Klage in Deutschland, eine Befragung im EU-Parlament, sowie auch diese Klage vor dem äh vor dem oder die die Anzeige vor dem äh EGMR. Wenn der Snowden Russland verlässt und nach Europa kommt,
dann kann, wer auch immer, also wenn ihnen da ein Parlament oder ein Gericht hineinlädt, können die sehr schwer für seine Sicherheit garantieren.
So, es wäre jetzt nicht verwunderlich, oder es würde jetzt keinen überraschen, wenn's Norden irgendwie was heißt, sagen wir mal nach Europa kommt und dann plötzlich, huch.
Wo abgeführt wird.
Hm. Das ist auch die Frage, wohin soll er denn überhaupt reisen? So, also was was könnte denn überhaupt das sichere Land sein?
Anderes Problem, aber der entscheidende Punkt ist, dass das eine Rolle spielen würde, wenn er vor dem EU-Parlament dann
als als irgendwie befragt vom EU-Parlament befragt werden. Das wäre jetzt noch nicht mal ein Gericht. Das wäre ja dann nur äh parlamentarisch eine parlamentarische Fragerunde oder sowas, ja.
Wenn er da anreist, wer soll ihn da, wer kann ihn da wirklich Schutz garantieren? Und das wär, äh, ist denke ich mal, in Europa, äh, ohne ähm
Deutschland und Frankreich kaum möglich. Bei den Briten ist nicht damit zu rechnen.
Ja, nicht wirklich, bei Italien auch nicht.
Interessante Frage
So, aber jetzt wollte ich noch ganz kurz sagen, ähm das habe ich gerade eingangs nicht erzählt. Die Befragung von Edwards Norden ist natürlich, wird natürlich auch in der Strafanzeige durch die ähm durch den CCC die internationale Liga für Menschenrechte und die Digitalcourage
gefordert. Wollte ich nur noch kurz.
Also wir werden sehen, wie sich ob sich irgendwie überhaupt für diese ganzen Befragungen und es kann gut sein, dass ähm das Norden sich da einer Fernbefragung verweigert. Ich meine, seine Hoffnung ist natürlich trotzdem irgendwie nach Deutschland zu kommen,
Der würde natürlich gerne in in Deutschland.
Hat sie ja jetzt auch gerade einen Anwalt in Kreuzberg genommen.
Genau, hat sich gerade einen deutschen Anwalt genommen und wenn der Punkt ist ja, er kann ja in Deutschland kein, also seine Asylanträge für Deutschland wurden ja mit der wunderschönen Begründung abgelehnt, ja, du bist leider gerade nicht in Deutschland, das ist Bedingungen für den Asylantrag in Deutschland
hat natürlich klar, es ist äh äh hat,
Gründe, dass das so ist. Deutschland möchte natürlich nicht für jeden, der politisch Verfolgten der Welt äh die Reisekosten tragen.
Aber da würde es ja ausreichen, dass er da in äh die deutsche Botschaft äh einmarschiert.
Da bin ich mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher.
Deutscher Boden.
Da bin ich mir, also da kenne ich das deutsche Asylrecht nicht ausreichend. Der entscheidende Punkt wäre, wenn man ihn jetzt für einen Strafverfahren tatsächlich nach Deutschland bekommen könnte, hätte er vermutlich auch so einen kleinen Brief in der Tasche, wo er sagt, ja.
Übrigens, Asyl, Alter.
Einmal Asyl und Reflex, bitte,
Weil die Flex braucht er ja gar nicht.
So, was haben wir noch?
So, was haben wir noch? Ja, das große, das groß angekündigte Projekt ist endlich äh gelauncht und das ist sogar heute passiert.
Ach, ist schon wieder was nicht mitbekommen?
Und hatte ja dann den von dem abgeworben und ähm.
Hat gesagt, hier wir machen einmal Medien so wie du möchtest und das Konzept, was sie da jetzt heute gelauncht haben, heißt wie,
ist aber nicht unter dieser Domain erreichbar, sondern ist eine Sub Domain von.
First Look.
First look und First look ist offenbar das ähm.
Diese diese neue Plattform und wie ist dann eben eine ein Format von. So würde ich das glaube ich ähm benennen. Und da ist er mit Laura Pointers.
Die ja auch schon die ganze Zeit mit ihm zusammen die ganzen Veröffentlichungen durchgeführt hat.
Mit der das eigentlich seit vom Beginn an macht. Und ähm,
hat dort heute eine die Rolle der NSA in den Drohnenmorden,
behandelt. Das ist also der der erste Artikel heute vom zehnten Februar, in dem behandelt wird, wie die ähm die über die elektronische Überwachung durch die NSA zur Zielfindung für tödliche Drohnenangriffe,
ähm beiträgt.
Das ist also jetzt, das ist jetzt offensichtlich das neue Ding, was man lesen möchte, ist First Look für eben erste,
erster Hand Analysen aus dem aus dem Hause Green World Pointers und,
sie nehmen da auch Gastbeiträge auf, unter anderem hier den von Travel Packlin, der übrigens auch beim Kongress einen vielbeachteten Vortrag gehalten hat.
Genau, der, ja, sozusagen schon seit längerem die Geheimdienste äh beobachtet, haben wir auch glaube ich drauf äh hingewiesen. Ähm als wir unseren dreißig C drei Review gemacht haben, das ist äh ein ganz toller äh Vortrag ist.
Also seine Arbeit ist da jetzt auch nicht äh so brandneu, aber jetzt gibt's irgendwie neue Fotos, Videos hier von äh den ganzen Niederlassungen, der einzelnen äh amerikanischen Geheimdienste. Alles sehr schön, alles sehr.
Nachtaufnahmen. Er ist Künstler, muss man dazu sagen, kein äh das ist ein paar schöne Nachtaufnahmen im Sonnen dazu. Das ist also jetzt die neue Quelle, die in jedem Feed wieder gehört. So, jetzt müssen wir.
Die neue, die Meldung ist natürlich auch sehr interessant, nicht wahr? Also wie ich's richtig mitbekommen habe, ich habe das heute Morgen so überfluten. Mir war das jetzt noch gar nicht klar, dass das jetzt schon das neue Projekt ist, also dieser Artikel, den hatte ich vor der Nase. Ähm
Kernaussage ist das NSA halt auch eine Menge der Daten liefert, die letzten Endes zu den Drohneneinsätzen führen und dementsprechend auch dafür mitverantwortlich sind, das selbige Fehlschlagen,
Weil eben diese ganze Datenanalyse auch jetzt nicht unbedingt so zuverlässig ist, wie man sich das vielleicht immer wünscht.
Ähm interessant ist dazu, also für mich ist da ja man muss da,
Das ist natürlich irgendwie ein Ding, was man den Leuten auch erstmal erklären muss, ne. Also ich find's ich find's irgendwie ziemlich offensichtlich, dass äh diese Überwachungszeit natürlich dann am Ende auch unmittelbar mit mit den Drohnenangriffen in Verbindung stehen,
Ähm,
Wer da mal eine Buchempfehlung haben möchte, können wir ja mal machen. Das Buch von äh Daniel Suares setzt sich äh mit,
genau dieser Art auseinander, wie also äh Drohnenangriffe funktionieren,
und wie äh da die Verbindung zwischen den Geheimdiensten und den und dem Militär eben an keiner Stelle so absolut fließend ist wie dort, ne.
Geht allein schon damit los, dass die Drohnen eben zur letzten Ortung ihres Ziels äh eingebaute INSE-Katcher haben, ja, um äh.
Ist aber Fiction jetzt hier eigentlich.
Das ist ein absolutes Fiction-Buch noch.
Noch.
Ja, nein, aber das ist mir das äh ich habe das vor äh vor zwei Wochen irgendwie äh mal ist mir das so durch,
aufgefallen, also nee, oder vor einer Woche, als es mit diesem äh Kram losging, ja, als das rauskam, also GCACHQS Kampf gegen Enonemis. Da in dem Moment,
ist das Buch Little Brother von Corry Doktor, nämlich vom Dystopie Regal in das Retro-Futurismusregal gewandert.
Innerhalb von, weiß nicht, das Buch ist vier Jahre alt oder so, höchstens, ne? Und das, was, was Korry Doktor da beschrieben hat.
Ähm mit kämpft gegen eine kleine Gruppe von Teenagern, die irgendwie verschlüsselt kommunizieren und für und als Terroristen gelten. Das ist ja jetzt inzwischen,
überholt,
Also da hat das gesamte Buch, in dem gesamten Buch kommt nichts drin vor, was die Realität jetzt nicht schon eingeholt hatte und das hat er, in welchem Jahr geschrieben, du machst den Link gerade auf
Wann hat Corre Doktor? Ich würde jetzt so vier Jahre schätzen, ja, er scheint drei Jahre, Erscheinungstermin erst dann oder ist das jetzt die doch erster November zweitausendelf veröffentlicht?
Zumindest jetzt diese konkrete Ausgabe hier gerade. Ich weiß es.
Okay, kann auch älter sein, ne?
Ist, äh wir können das auch mal anders professioneller nachschlagen, aber.
Roman.
Zweitausendacht.
Zweitausendacht, also sechs Jahre her. Oder fünfeinhalb. So, das Ding wurde irgendwie formuliert, so fünfeinhalb Jahre später ist diese diese dieses dystopische,
Buch komplett eingeholt. Wobei der jetzt nicht besonders äh also das spielte schon auch in der Jetztzeit und äh ihm oder zehn Jahre äh zehn Jahre später oder sowas, ne. Es war jetzt nicht so in der absoluten Zukunft.
Die Science-Fiction hat's nicht einfach in diesen Zeiten.
Nicht einfach.
Da muss man jetzt auch ein bisschen schneller sein.
Und da wird eben der der Abbau des äh Rechtsstaates durch äh das Department of Homeladet Security beschrieben. So und dieses Buch, wie gesagt, da kommt nichts mit oder ich kann mich an keine Stelle in diesem Buch erinnern, ist länger her, dass ich's gelesen habe,
die jetzt nicht schon,
von der Realität eingeholt worden wäre und bei von Daniels ähm da ist es ist man jetzt auch nicht mehr so weit davon entfernt leider.
Gibt's da nur ein Buch von oder was gibt's hier steht nochmal Homeland dazu, gibt's da noch einen zweiten.
Homeland ist wahrscheinlich die deutsch Übersetzung, oder? Würde ich jetzt vermuten. Das.
Ach so. Weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau. Wir werden das nachliefern. Die Links auf die Bücher in den.
Genau
Beide äh beide sehr zu empfehlen und äh äh Little Brother müsste eigentlich irgendwie unter einer Creative Linse stehen und frei herunterladbar irgendwo zu finden sein. Und da gibt's auch ein Hörbuch, was mal jemand eingesprochen hat. Das war auch unter äh CC Lizenz.
Nicht.
Gut.
Wir verplappern uns hier schon wieder.
Ja, damit haben wir dann, glaube ich, äh die Snotenwoche auch erst mal arbeitet, also zu dem Drohnenkomplex. Man weiß, glaube ich, nicht weiter.
Nee, da müssen wir uns irgendwann mit der laden wir uns mal den Norbert irgendwann ein hier.
Machen wir. Ja.
Victoria Newland gilt als wichtigster Europaberaterin von Obama und äh es fand sich.
Neuland. Programm.
Der Name ist der Name ist Programm, hat jetzt auch mit ist jetzt mit dem Neuland in Kontakt geraten? Nee, die hatte eine.
Eher mit dem Alten Land würde ich.
Genau, mit dem allen, nein, sie hatte eine private Unterhaltung mit Jeffrey. Wahrscheinlich?
Also was heißt privat? Also sie hatte einen nichtöffentliche äh Unterhaltung, die aber sicherlich beruflicher Natur war, sagen wir es mal so.
Ja, es war jetzt nicht ja, es war jetzt nicht Privates gesorgt. Also.
Muss man schon unterscheiden finden.
Eine nichtöffentliche Unterhalte, ein Telefonat mit dem US-Botschafter in der Ukraine. Und ähm in diesem,
Telefonat ging es um die politischen Ziele der EU, was den Konflikt in der Ukraine gerade angeht und die politischen Ziele der USA
Was diesen Konflikt angeht und da gibt es offensichtlich bestimmte unterschiedliche Auffassungen, wie denn da jetzt gerade zu verfahren wäre. Und dann sagte sie, äh,
An einer Stelle in diesem mehr minütigen Mitschnitt, der da veröffentlicht wurde.
Was, wenn man sich das anhört, na ja, es ist halt so, wie wie man das halt so sagt im Sinne von, ja, hier Scheiß
Scheiß auf die EU, ist uns doch egal, was die jetzt da wollen. Äh das ist unsere Agenda. Wir gehen jetzt hier in diese Richtung und unterstützen diese Personen oder diese nicht. Also irgendwie Klitschko kam da nicht so gut weg
ähm da wird wohl generell noch nicht so unbedingt für voll genommen, also
Schwergewichts Boxweltmeisterschaften. Alleine zählen jetzt in der Politik äh da äh noch nicht so viel offensichtlich. Nachvollziehbar,
Und äh ja, offensichtlich ist halt dieses Telefonat abgehört worden von den Russen, was jetzt.
Nö, das kann man nicht offensichtlich sein, deshalb muss man offenbar sagen. Also es ist, es gibt keinen Beleg, wer es abgehört hat.
Okay, offensichtlich offenbar ist das überhaupt so viel anderes äh Wort, sagen wir es mal anders. Es macht den Eindruck, als ob es äh russisch geprägte äh Kräfte gibt, die sich äh eines Mitschnitts haben,
äh ja der geworden sind und äh bemächtigt haben
und äh dann auch versucht dann auch offensichtlich ähm sagen wir mal zu seiner Veröffentlichung beizutragen. Also es gab da irgend so einen Russen, der das dann getwittert hat und so
und dann YouTube, YouTube-Panner, also es wurde richtig ausgekostet. So, ah, komm, da stellen wir jetzt mal online. Und ähm ist natürlich sehr interessant.
Erstmal ich weiß gar nicht, ob's das überhaupt schon mal in der Form so gegeben hat. Ja, also dass man jetzt so,
bewusst über das Internet so ein Mitschnitt veröffentlicht hat, also weiß man nicht, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht gab's das schon regelmäßig, vielleicht wie die Hälfte von dem, was wir so in der Tagesschau präsentiert bekommen, äh über solche Kanäle veröffentlicht worden. Nur,
man merkt dem halt schon an, dass da die Russen dann wiederum ihre Agenda noch äh interessanter fanden und hier gerne mal da den Spaltpilz zwischen USA und äh Europa geworfen haben,
Hier in Deutschland hat man sich dann ganz äh schön aufgeregt, also zumindest haben die deutschen,
Medien, das äh wunderbar aufgegriffen und ich glaube, der ein oder andere Bundestagsabgeordnete hätte auch gerne was zu dieser Debatte gesagt.
Na, warte nur ganz kurz. Also ich würde das echt nochmal gerne also ein was wie bewerten wir denn jetzt überhaupt diese Aktion?
Welche Aktion? Denn die der Russen oder die das Gespräch?
Also genau, erstmal das Gespräch. Also das Gespräch selber muss ich sagen, finde ich.
Ist halt ein normales ist ja, ist ein normales Hintergrundgespräch. So reden die halt und aus diesem Fakt, ich meine, wenn sie sich jetzt vor ein Mikrofon gestellt hätte, ja, in einer öffentlichen Ansprache gesagt hätte, äh,
ja, dann würde ich sagen, entlassen tschüss, setzen sechs.
Aber in einem privaten Gespräch äh in einem nichtöffentlichen, in einer nichtöffentlichen Interredung unter.
Ist das vollkommen normale amerikanische Sprache. Ich meine, die machen da zwar öffentlich immer einen Clim Bim drum rum und ein Sternchen durchs Ohr, aber äh so redet halt der Amerikaner.
Das heißt, dieses Gespräch wurde dann veröffentlicht und ähm,
es gibt natürlich in diesem Gespräch mehr als dieses Faktor, aber natürlich ist das Fakt der EU, denn das, was äh was Medien aufgreifen können. Wie du gerade schon sagtest, ihre,
Gesamteinschätzung der Situation und ihre Wünsche, was da passieren soll, sind sicherlich für einige ähm Gruppen und Menschen noch sehr, sehr viel interessanter im Moment.
Ja, aber da müsste man sich ja dann mit den Inhalten auseinandersetzen. Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer so gewünscht.
Genau. So, aber jetzt gibt's diesen äh jetzt gibt's diese Situation und vermutlich ähm russische Kräfte äh
schaffen es irgendwie dieses Gespräch aufzuzeichnen und online zu schalten. Mit welchem also
weshalb machen sie das um? Weitere Zwietracht zu sehen zwischen den USA und Deutschland oder machen sie's um ähm deren beider oder insbesondere die,
Verhandlungspositionen der USA äh zu schwächen, indem sie ihre Interessen offenlegen.
Oder machen sie's, um zu zeigen, ey, übrigens können wir auch.
Oder all love.
Immer, das ist ja immer das Ding, so bei einem kalten Krieg.
Ja oder das ist sicherlich so eine keine Ahnung,
macht so den Eindruck, als könnte alles irgendwie so ein bisschen passen, hat ihn halt einfach grade gut in den Kram gepasst. Auch um vielleicht so in der Ukraine so ein bisschen dieses Bild zu liefern. Ja, hier die anderen, die sind auch nur am falschen über euch.
Ja, also schwer schwer zu sagen, ist auch schwer zu sagen, ob das jetzt so als Group letztlich äh intern so gefeiert wird oder ob man sich nicht damit mittelfristig auch ein Eigentor geschossen hat,
schwer zu sagen.
Ist nämlich die Frage, ja. Auf jeden Fall, es gab dann also Sprecherin fand sofort die richtigen Worte für diese Aktion und bezeichnete sie als einen neuen Tiefstand der russischen Spionage-Taktik.
Ja, also, das ist auch echt krass, wie wir hier die ganze Zeit mit neuen Tiefständen der russischen Spionage-Taktik konfrontiert werden, ne?
Ich bin auch echt völlig außer mir. Der ein Tisch stand nach dem anderen. Man würde sich wundern,
ne, dass sie noch nicht mal ein Fuck bieten in der Aufzeichnung, ja? Ist echt Tiefstand.
Ja, das ist schon lustig.
Und äh die Sprecherin erklärte dann auch,
äh die gute Front Neuland hätte ihre EU-Partner kontaktiert und sich natürlich entschuldigt. Was ist das denn für eine affige? Aber das ist ja bei bei Diplomatie immer wichtig, ne, dass man dann anruft und sagte, ja Entschuldigung, tut mir leid und dass man dann zu
Wenn sowas ist, dass man das dann, dass man sich dann entschuldigt. Entschuldigung, es spielt in der Diplomatie eine große Rolle.
Ja, das ist ja dann auch in Ordnung und äh was soll sie denn auch so anderes tun? Ich meine an der Stelle hat sie dann einfach keine andere Chance, aber ich glaube auch letztlich nicht, dass ich irgend ihr äh irgendjemand da jetzt aus diesem,
Wort diesem Satz, ja, diesem Hinweis, irgendein Strick draußen,
weil die wissen ja alle, wie sie selber äh drüber reden, ja. Und ich meine, sie werden auch genauso da am Telefon sitzen und sagen, scheiß auf die Amis.
Absolut richtig, deswegen es, ich glaube, deswegen hat sich auch für die ähm als als Decables irgendwie rauskam, da hat sich ja keiner für entschuldigt, äh zu sagen, wie was sie von den Deutschen hielten. Das ist ja schon längst wieder vergessen.
Wie gesagt, also auch der Bundestag hätte halt auch gerne da auch eine Meinung zu, nur das ging halt gerade nicht so gut, weil sie saßen also in ihren Büros und versuchten halt jetzt diese Artikel zu klicken, aber die wurden dann leider vom äh internen Pornfilter äh,
aufgesogen. So wurde es zumindest berichtet. Ich halte das für halbwegs glaubhaft, zumindest möchte ich das gerne glauben. Ich weiß nicht, wie siehst du das?
Was äh möchte ich glauben?
Na ja das der gemeine Bundestagsabgeordnete auf diese Berichterstattung klicken wollte im Netz aber leider dann weil ja da die ganze Zeit über Fuck äh geredet wurde, halt der Pornofilter äh Griff und eben den Zugriff auf diese URLs nicht.
Halte ich für absolut äh realistisch.
Ja, ist doch schön, ne? Deswegen, deswegen brauchen wir halt solche äh Zensurfilter. Ja, ist sehr gut, weil dann kann man sich nämlich in so einer Debatte äh schön auf dem Laufenden halten.
Ja, also das, ich meine, ich meine ich war schon tatsächlich überrascht, dass es einen Pornfilter im Bundestag gibt,
Also ich hätte jetzt so nicht den Eindruck, dass die machen jetzt nicht den Eindruck einer Institution, wo es einen Pornfilter gibt. So von der allgemeinen Produktivität und.
Man kann jetzt lange darüber diskutieren, ob die Produktivität steigt mit oder ohne Portfilter, also das ist äh.
Darüber habe ich ja auch keine Aussage getroffen.
War auf jeden Fall ganz lustig.
Unseren Spaß mit solchen Meldungen. Aber das ist halt einfach dieses äh Filtern hat einfach am Ende zu stattzufinden und nicht irgendwo mittendrin.
So. Kommen wir zu weiteren äh unbeschädigten Gerüchten.
Überfiltern, über mittendrin filtern. Das war ein ein ähm.
Kleiner Aufreger.
Keiner Aufreger. Äh Netflix ist ein Anbieter in den USA für äh Streaming-Video,
Da kann man auf, also ich ich habe Netflix selber nicht, ist der Größte, ja. Äh ich habe das selber nicht, aber ähm ein Kumpel von mir hat das, da kann man irgendwie Fernsehen gucken. Kannst du, glaube ich, irgendwie alle Filme schauen. Das heißt.
Genau. Hatten wir ja auch letztes Mal schon, als wir hier über diese DAM-Geschichte äh gesprochen haben, weil sie sind halt mit diesem DVD-Verleih groß geworden und äh gehen jetzt zunehmenden Maße ins Netz und.
Und das ist eigentlich eine legale Videoflatrate, oder? Also man zahlt irgendwie so irgendwas.
Netflix hat halts geschafft, irgendwie Deals mit äh Hollywood und ähm weiß nicht, anderen Quellen. Filme.
Ja, kann man auch sagen, also Netflix hat ja einfach schon, also in USA ist das einfach mittlerweile ein, ein, ein Well-None-Brand, ja? Es gibt hier mit whatch ever ähnliche Bestrebungen, äh im Prinzip ist das quasi so der Videoverleih über Internet.
Genau und das heißt, am Ende äh übertragen die sehr viel, sehr viel Daten,
Und so sagt man, zu Spitzenzeiten bis zu dreißig Prozent des US Traffics. Also Spitzenzeit heißt dann, dass eine, dass es eine Uhrzeit gibt, wo die Nutzer sehr viel Netflix nutzen und das, was dann an Bandbreite ist, davon sind's dreißig Prozent, ja?
Nicht, dass sie insgesamt dreißig Prozent des Internet-Traffics hätten. Ähm und jetzt ist natürlich der haben wir wieder das das,
klassische Beispiel, das klassische Netzneutralitätsbeispiel, es gibt auf einmal einen einen Anbieter, der für eine ganze Menge Traffic äh verantwortlich ist. Es hat so auch schon den Eye-Player von BBC in den im Königreich getroffen
Es hat äh gibt solche Debatten immer wieder mit äh YouTube. Es gibt.
Mit Google, ja.
Mit Google zwischen also genau die gleiche Debatte gibt's zwischen Google, für YouTube und den und den den großen Magentafarbenen Tee,
Und jetzt äh zeigte sich irgendwie oder mehrten sich die Hinweise, die dann einen einen Blogger dokumentierte, dass,
Seinen Anbieter.
Die Verbindungen auf vierzig Kilo pro Sekunde bremst. Was sehr langsam ist.
Ja, zumindest hat er das so messen können.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, Netflix betreibt aber gar kein eigenes riesiges Datenzentrum oder,
zumindest keins, wo diese dreißig Prozent des gesamten US Internet-Traffics zur gegebenen Zeit an Video rauskommen, sondern sie nutzen AWS, Amazon, Amazon, Webservices.
Wie fast alle. Und wenn.
Ich dann sage, ich möchte die Netflix-Videos bremsen, dann muss ich eben einfach mal die gesamte Amazon-Cloud bremsen und das ist auch der Grund, warum es dem äh Blogger dann da aufgefallen ist, weil
er selber irgendwie auch was in der Amazon Cloud da hatte und äh sagte ja von zu Hause, kriegt er das irgendwie nur ganz langsam
und von äh von seiner Arbeitsstelle kriegt er es ähm.
Problemlos. Und der Unterschied äh ist oder das sogar bei gleichem Routing, also wäre ungefähr gleich.
Bis auf den Unterschied natürlich, dass es am Ende durch Horizont kommt bei seiner Arbeitsstätte, wo er kein Horizon hat durch einen anderen Provider. Und dann das hat ihn dann ähm,
der Vermutung verleitet, aha, erst vor wenigen Wochen,
hat ja dieser dieses schöne Gericht die Regulation des des FC als illegal oder als nicht rechtmäßig abgeurteilt und damit die,
gesetzmäßig, gesetzlich verbriefte Netzneutralität in den USA wieder abgeschafft und benannte das dann eben als die offenbar,
erste Folge, die erste Folge dieser Entscheidung, nämlich, dass jetzt die Kämpfe zwischen zwei großen.
Teilmonopalisten Monopolisten, fast Monopolisten, Marktmächten, einer der Inhalte anbietet und anderer, der sein Geld momentan noch damit verbiegt, verdient Nutzern den Zugang zu diesen Inhalten zu ermöglichen,
Und eben die Folge, dass jetzt also derjenige, der dessen Geschäfts bis jetzt darin lag, Nutzern den Zugang zu den Inhalten,
zu ermöglichen, jetzt auch das Geschäftsmodell eröffnen möchte. Inhalte, Anbietern den Zugang zu seinen Nutzern zu ermöglichen.
Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, dass das Ganze irgendwie immer noch so ein bisschen im spekulativen Bereich ist, weil Horizon hat äh mittlerweile gesagt, dass sie das nicht tun.
Ja, also dass dieser Vorfall ja
keine Ahnung, was auch immer da waren. Also es bekam ja Brisanz, dieser Blogpost äh von diesem Menschen wie Jeser noch gleich, weiß ich jetzt grad nicht. Der hat ja äh gesagt, er wäre ja danach äh in den in den Chat gegangen und hätte sich eben mit so einem so Reisen-Support-Menschen da unterhalten und,
habe bestätigt, ja also das gibt da Screenshots und so weiter, wo er eben meint, so ja, das diese Drosselung sei halt von Bereisen aus so der Fall.
Nur dass halt Horizon jetzt äh der Meinung ist, dem sei halt nicht so. Es gibt halt zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder äh der Typ lag falsch oder äh Horizon,
zählt äh die Unwahrheit,
Das Ergebnis kennen wir nicht. Es ist nur so, dass jetzt, soweit ich das bisher wahrgenommen habe, es auch niemand anderen gab, der jetzt.
Dieseselbe Drosselung beobachtet hat,
und dann betrachtet Tatsache, dass es dann nicht wenig Kunden geben dürfte, die auf Netflix zugreifen, ja. Ich meine vierzig Kilo Bike pro Sekunde, das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, für Video-Streaming.
Einfach jenseits von Gut und Böse. Das ist halt einfach, geht nicht. So und wenn jetzt irgendwie Netflix bei allen Horizon Kunden auf einmal nicht ginge,
Wäre das, glaube ich, sehr schnell größere äh News als nur ein Blogpost von irgendjemanden. Keine Ahnung. Also letztlich es droht äh nach wie vor äh sehr interessant finde ich, dass äh hier dann auch,
auf wie hieß noch vielleicht Test verwiesen wurde, also Web
Seiten, wo man dann eben selber äh testen kann, ob über die eigene Leitung bestimmte Dienste eben schneller oder langsamer sind und wo dann eben auch zentral äh Informationen darüber,
gesammelt werden. Ich denke, mit solchen Systemen sollte es künftig auch schnell möglich sein, wenn irgendwo der Verdacht entsteht, eben auch wirklich äh konkret zu belegen, wie denn die Situation da ist. Und wenn solche belastbaren Zahlen vorliegen, dann wird's nochmal interessant sein
zu sehen, wie die politische Bewertung davon ist. Aber so oder so, wir leben jetzt äh in so Zeiten, wo es,
droht nicht nur in den USA, auch in Europa, auch in Deutschland, ähm dass wir eben diese Beschränkungen von Anbietern bekommen werden und ja, das ist natürlich gerade für so unabhängige Sender,
wie auch die Mieterebene, unter Umständen bald ein Problem, ne. Ich meine, ich bin jetzt nicht.
Ganz ich finde ich finde es nicht nur ein Problem für den unabhängigen Sender, ist ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Problem und auch ein Problem für das gesamte Internet, wie wir es kennen. Also nichts ist,
So wichtig für das Internet,
wie Netzneutralität. Also selbst mit einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung bleiben uns unter Umständen technische Mittel, um die Freiheit aufrecht zu erhalten, ja? Ähm mit Überwachung ähm,
Damit du noch größere Überwachung ebenso, da können wir uns immer gegen wehren. Zumindest theoretisch, aber wenn,
Die Verletzungen der Netzneutralität erstmal,
sich etabliert haben und wir uns daran gewöhnt haben, irgendwie fünf Euro extra zu bezahlen, um auch Soundcloud zu haben,
Ja, das äh dann also dann ist es wirklich vorbei. Das ist wirklich, also HTML fünf im Browser, Vorratsdatenspeicherung und so weiter, das ist alles nicht so wichtig für die,
Für den Kern des Internets, wie die Netzneutralität selber. Es gibt nichts Wichtigeres.
Ich habe das jetzt aber bewusst auch noch mal so formuliert, dass ich sage, es ist für mich als kleines Unternehmen, also bei mir jetzt von einem Unternehmen zu sprechen, halte ich schon in gewisser Hinsicht vermessen, ja, aber äh sagen wir mal, äh also ich ich spreche,
genau. Ich als als Privatkonzern ähm.
Ich als kleiner mittelständischer Konzern.
Naja, aber wie heißt das so schön? Äh kleine und mittelständische Unternehmen, KMU, ja? Äh die würde ich jetzt mal ganz bewusst ansprechen. Also wer uns jetzt hier auch zuhört und äh sich vielleicht in diesem Segment,
angesiedelt sieht so. Ich bin ein äh ein Unternehmen, ich möchte mit Internet irgendetwas tun und für uns sind äh Bandbreiten nicht unerheblich. Es muss ja nicht nur Videostraining oder Audio-Streaming sein, sondern es kann ja auch äh andere Datendienste sein.
Ja, irgendwas, Services, Auslagerungen, Outsourcing in irgendeiner Form. Äh die sollten sich mal ganz schleunigst an ihren äh Abgeordneten wenden,
einfach mal sagen, dass ihr einfach aus wirtschaftlichen Erwägungen das für eine Schnapsidee haben. Also nicht nur für eine Schnapsidee, sondern für eine Bedrohung halten.
Ja, aber wir stehen noch, der eben was hat die SPD in den SPD Heini gerade wieder von sich gegeben? Der Mittelstand muss in die Cloud.
Ja und wenn der Mittelstand aber in die Cloud will, dann äh muss man ihn da halt auch reinlassen und nicht durch solche Maßnahmen.
Ja, wäre ja blöd, also der Cloud-Anbieter könnte ja dann wieder Deals haben, aber als es ist schlecht, es ist schlecht äh und.
Genau, aber ich wollte einfach exklusiv mal darauf hinweisen, wer das jetzt hier hört und sich einfach in so einer Firma befindet, äh die in irgendeiner Form das Gefühl hat, das Internet könnte in den nächsten zehn oder zwanzig Jahren vielleicht nochmal eine Rolle für diese Firma spielen. Ja, ist davon betroffen.
Und es ist auf jeden Fall ein Nachteil für euch.
Letztes Thema. Das ist äh da da müssen wir eigentlich der, der, der allgemeinen Berichterstattung entgegen äh wirken. Und zwar geht es um die Urheberrechtshinweise in Bildern. Ja, da war jetzt irgendwie der große
der große Aufschrei,
neuerdings der Urheberrechtshinweis im Bild sichtbar sein muss und zwar will ich jetzt ganz kurz den Fall erklären.
Auch wieder Köln, ja, also in Köln haben wir jetzt neu. Köln ist das neue Hamburg oder so, da kommt der neueste Mist her. Ähm,
Also ist eine an eine äh eine äh Plattform im Internet, wo man sich anmelden kann, seine Bilder hochlädt. Und diese Bilder dann quasi zum Lizens,
Erwerb zur Verfügung stellen kann,
Dann können andere Nutzer hingehen, das Bild dort kaufen und die die Nutz oder die die Nutzungslizenz für dieses Bild dort erwerben,
Pixelot streichende Provision ein und man selber kriegt irgendwie äh dann einen Teil dieses Betrages, ja. Also so eine Art App Store für
Fotos. Kann man als Hobbyfotograf einfach mal seine Sachen reinwerfen, ordentlich taggen unter Umständen verdient man halt ein paar Mark damit, ja?
Jetzt hatte eine ähm Firma dort ein Bild zur Illustration eines Artikels erworben und verwendet.
Und gemäß den Lizenzbedingungen von Pixelio, dort auch den Urheber und die Quelle vermerkt, das heißt, da muss man dann irgendwie schreiben, wettet man das Bild ein und unten drunter steht dann Foto, Hans Wurst.
Und jetzt hatte der,
Hans Worst, der betroffene Hanswurst, hat dann eine Abmahnung geschickt, weil es auf einer Übersichtsseite keinen Quellenhinweis gab. Ähm das verstehe ich so, dass sie quasi das
Bild irgendwie im Artikel selber stand dann drunter, Bildhans Wurst, aber auf der Startseite vielleicht nicht, weil's Artikelbild war oder so. So habe ich das hier an der Stelle verstanden.
Und dann haben die, hat die äh Betroffene, die beklagte Firma dann diese Abmahnung äh zurückgewiesen.
Und dann haben sie eine Klage bekommen von dem Hanswurst. Der nämlich dann sagte, na ja, ihr habt einen direkt Link auf die Bilddatei, das heißt, es gibt einen Link, den man klicken kann und dann kommt nur das Bild,
Und wenn man dann dieses Bild sieht, dann ist da kein Hinweis, nämlich so dann ist sie, also quasi, es gibt gar kein HTML mehr, sondern es kommt nur das Bild. Dann sehe ich keinen Hinweis.
Und dann sagt selbst Pixilia, dieser Anbieter,
Das ist auch nicht notwendig. Ja, also war da auf Seiten des äh der der Firma, die dieses Bild, die die Nutzungsrechte an diesem Bild erworben hatte und sagte, laut unseren AGB, ähm,
da wird eine Kennzeichnung bei Einzelansicht empfohlen, aber das betrifft ja dann sowas wie,
eine Einzelseite, wo dann trotzdem nochmal HTML drum herum ist. Das heißt, selbst Pixel hat gesagt, ähm,
dass dass die Firma hier im Recht war, dass und das Bild ordnungsgemäß gekennzeichnet hat und sagen, weiter, die Bildverwender,
sind für die Browser-Funktionalität eine Bilddatei separat anzuzeigen, nicht verantwortlich zu machen, also die Möglichkeit, rechte Maustaste Bild einzeln anzeigen,
So und dieser gute Hobbyfotograf hat aber dann vom,
Gericht recht bekommen, denn die AGB von Pixelio empfehlen ja die Kennzeichnung bei Einzelansicht und deswegen hat der Nutzer äh hat die Firma gegen die AGB verstoßen, selbst wenn Pixilio der Ansicht ist, dass es nicht so ist.
Und das Gericht betont auch weiterhin, es ist eine Einzelfallentscheidung, die sich auf die AGB von Pixelio bezieht.
Bist du dir eigentlich sicher, dass jetzt in diesem äh durchgeklagten Fall tatsächlich explizit nochmal einen Link im HTML auf das Bild als solche existierte?
Dessen bin ich mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Ich will nur ganz kurz die Konsequenzen, ähm die Konsequenzen äh benennen, nämlich die Konsequenz ist,
Wenn also laut diesem Gerichtsurteil muss man, wenn man bei Pixilio ein Bild kauft,
beziehungsweise die Lizenzrechte zur Nutzung dieses Bildes ersteht in das Bild selber noch einmal reinschreiben wer es gemacht hat,
Und das hat sogar das dieses äh Landgericht Köln selber gemacht auf ihrer Staatsseite. Da waren nämlich irgendwie, da haben sie auch ein Bild, wo dann irgendwie nach Verkündung dieses Urteils auf einmal plötzlich unten links ganz klein drin stand, Foto äh Otto sonst weh,
Also ihr habt's quasi selber nochmal gemacht, weil sie ja ähm.
Und das Interessante ist, dass die AGBs von solchen Verwertungs äh Fotoverwertungs äh Anbietern. Genau das eigentlich häufig verbieten, dass man an dem Bild noch einmal Veränderungen vornimmt.
Also völlig ein völlig hanebüchendes Urteil von,
Richtern. Und äh Thorsten Klein schreibt dann sogar, also hat andere AGBs und ist deshalb nicht betroffen. Also so ein völlig
beknacktes Urteil. Man fragt sich wirklich wie blöd dieser Fotograf ist und wie viel Zeit der hat, um so einen Scheiß herbeizuführen,
ja? Und jetzt müssen die natürlich in Berufung gehen.
Und.
Und dieses dieses dieses äh dieses Urteil irgendwie da aus der Welt schaffen, damit das nicht rechtskräftig wird. Also völlig
knackt und die entsprechende ähm die der entsprechende kurze äh ja jetzt sage ich schon wieder,
Die entsprechende kurze Panik, die dann eben durch die Medien ging, weil so, was müssen wir jetzt im Web irgendwie in jedes Bild, den, den, den, den, den reinschreiben, was natürlich auch dann nochmal äh besonders äh Sport auf auf die,
Urheberrechtsumstände der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ziehen würde.
Also liegst du mir natürlich
zu, dass das mal wieder so ein bisschen weltfremd äh ist, ne? Also ruft aber ein paar interessante äh Fragen auf. Was man vielleicht noch nachliefern sollte, es gibt natürlich ein Statement von äh Pixelio, die haben sich äh einen Tag Zeit äh gelassen. Mittlerweile ist der ein Statement auch äh veröffentlicht
wo sie äh erstens ihr vollkommenes
Unverständnis äh über dieses Urteil zum Ausdruck geben, zweitens auch darauf hinweisen, dass sie selbstverständlich mit allen Fotografen, die auf diese Art und Weise gegen ihre Kunden vorgehen, äh die Geschäftsbeziehungen unmittelbar beenden werden.
Selbstverständlich.
Dann auch nochmal erklären, warum das eben wie du das eben auch gerade so schön gemacht hast im HTML Welten einfach sehr schwierig ist diesen Zugriff als solchen zu unterbinden, ja?
Wie gesagt, es wäre jetzt nochmal interessant, ob eben auf dieser Webseite ein Link auf das Bild selber drin,
oder nicht, das mag äh noch einen Unterschied machen, ja, weil du ja dann sozusagen,
Kraft deiner eigenen Webseite eben auf diesen Link hingeführt hast, äh alternativ müsste man sich halt diesen Link äh selber aus dem HTML herauspopeln, was zwar äh ein,
halbwegstechnisch mit dem Web äh vertrauten Menschen ohne Probleme äh möglich ist. Ich meine, da muss man nur so die Backfenster aufmachen im Browser, dann kriegt man das frei Haus geliefert. Da muss man noch nicht mal groß,
mit äh besonderen Tools arbeiten. Was ich mich bloß gefragt habe ist, inwiefern,
hier vielleicht auch neue Zwänge entstehen könnten. Diese Copyright Lizenzvereinbarung in die Bilder selber mit aufzunehmen.
Ja? Also.
In die Daten oder.
In die Mitterdaten. So, ist ja nicht so, dass das nicht möglich wäre, äh sowas da reinzunehmen. Ich habe
grad nicht so richtig die die Peilung, wie weit das da äh stabilisiert ist, aber es würde ja mit dem Teufel zugehen, wenn's nicht mindestens irgend so ein Copyright äh String gebe, den man da reinwerfen kann. Also es,
ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass es nicht möglich wäre, beziehungsweise ob man nicht vielleicht auch grundsätzlich darüber nachdenken sollte, dass eben solche Dienste oder auch Fotografen generell jeder, der äh quasi ein ein, ein, ein, ein Copyright,
wahrnehmen möchte oder ein Urheberrecht in dem Fall wahrnehmen möchte, dazu verpflichtet wird, eben das auch entsprechend korrekt darzustellen oder.
Im Fall, wo halt so ein Dienstleister ähm in Anspruch genommen wird, dass diese Bilder eben auch mit dieser korrekten Metainformation im Bild selber auch ausgeliefert werden
Ist ja kein Problem wäre. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das da der Fall ist, ja. Äh ich habe nur gesehen, dass da so drüber keiner redet. Weil in dem Moment könnte man ja auch sagen, äh,
Egal, wie da drauf gelingt wird, ja, das Bild selber äh enthält diese Information
Kann man natürlich hier dann wiederum fragen, na ja, welche welche Software zeigt denn das an? Welcher Browser schlägt in der Alarm? Welches Content Managementsystem äh reagiert auf solche Sachen,
Vermutlich keiner, ja oder wenn überhaupt, dann nur sehr wenige,
klar, aber ähm wäre ja durchaus auch mal ganz interessant, Urheber an der Stelle in die Pflicht zu nehmen, zumindest äh korrekte Maschinen lesbare Informationen zu liefern.
Um eben auch in einer automatisierten Verarbeitung da entsprechende äh Erkennungsmaßnahmen möglich zu machen,
Ja, sagen wir mal so, da kommt jetzt ein Bild in die Webseite, in diesen Workflow, in dieses Content Management System rein, wo nicht geklärt ist, also wo es keine gibt mit ja, das darf hier auch explizit verwendet werden
Ja, dieses Bild mit Kennung sowieso, Copyright vermerkt, trallala. Ähm das eben dann einfach auch eine Publikation gar nicht möglich,
ich will jetzt nicht so sehr hier in diese ganze Debatte mit reingehen, es wird auf jeden Fall sehr interessant äh sein zu sehen, wie das, was ist das Landgericht Köln,
Im Falle einer Revision, die wohl stattfinden wird, äh weiter verfahren wird.
Ja.
So. Gäbe sicherlich noch ein paar kleinere Themen, auf die man noch eingehen könnte, aber wir müssen an der Stelle jetzt mal Schluss machen. Ähm,
und vielleicht nächste Woche weiteres äh nachliefern, ist ja noch das ein oder andere äh passiert, was vielleicht äh eine Erwähnung wert gewesen wäre. Aber ist alles so Kleinkram.
Genau und deshalb beenden wir das jetzt hier.
Genau. Wir sagen tschüss und bis bald. Tschau, tschau.
Ciao, ciao.